you brought some more gifts yeah okay
what other gifts did you bring well I
know there's a classic japanese delicacy
that you haven't really uh shown off
much why would you bring this we have
shown this off have you I think we've
shown this off on an episode one you
know call me degenerate I actually kind
of like I don't like good get the [__] I
actually kind of like these it's called
Maru and what is this Cherry tell us
tell the audience what it is uh this is
um Maru which is basically uh Japanese
sake in a GL cup how much would this
cost it's about 110 Yen so it's like the
cheapest 80 cents for 200 M of hard
alcohol I think every country that's POG
POG about it [__] it's so cheap and it's
sck it's Japanese every country has an
equivalent of [__] that's like super
cheap that you only drink when you're
like really really young are we comping
do I have to Campa I already took a sip
oh my
God oh God
new newbie
Camp Jesus guys I'm jet lagged as
[__] I don't like sake well people loved
your drunk episode so yeah well I don't
think I'm going to get drunk today not
with this [__] I got it I need some nice
nice
alcohol what the [__] Mudan what Mudan
what why did you down that well I mean M
was the small why are you so unhinged is
it not a shot glass no okay rule number
okay I'm going to tell the audience this
especially Americans did you shot that
yeah why I'm I'm going to say 200 M I'm
going to say this on camera okay
Americans sake is not meant to be shoted
you are not supposed to shot sake it's a
sippy drink M you're not supposed to
shot sake it's a sippy drink why is it
in such a small bottle then this is 200
M what do you mean this is a lot of sake
it's just a big shot Cup oh you could
say that about any vessel you say that
about this no he's he can't
shotting I can see the I can see the
cogs turning I'm going to shot this
water dare me again this is what happens
when you have an an aonian
on that's not
bad it's actually not bad he he just
doesn't like sake same with this gu I
don't like this kind of oh Christ it's
like lighter fluid what that's really
nice what this is how you treat your
guests when they bring gifts a gift you
brought me the Dollar
Store what do they uh what do they drink
in Estonia normally I guess
vka [__] H yeah I guess like that's
one thing I wanted to ask is like I've
been AR and I have been wanting to like
uh go to Estonia just because we know
someone in Estonia now um what what's it
like like cuz I think before meeting you
i' knew nothing of Estonia didn't even
know Estonia existed I know Estonia is
like Hightech is it Hightech it is
pretty Hightech oh really we have like
uh you can do why did you live in a why
did you live in a log cabin then do you
can you choose where you're born or
where you live in the first years are
you like are you like why are you poor
is I didn't mean to like that why you P
me then damn why hold up you live in a
log cabin oh yeah my mom had a log cabin
like outside the city like own wait it
was a house it made out of
logs like
when you say l cabin you just usually
mean like a resort or something but it's
it's a house right right okay okay and
you you live there growing up or yeah
and you had a good internet there no
that's why like everything that I pretty
much do in life to advance is because of
trash taste I moved to the city to have
better internet to download your insane
like files upgraded my PC like changed
uh routs everything wow well you're
welcome first of
all now you can game at fast
speed when did realize you really liked
editing cuzz like you you said you got
into YouTube to do like just content and
[__] but now you I feel like you're
definitely just like you are the only
editor I know this can sound bad you're
the only editor I know that actually
enjoys the process of editing as opposed
to like I like editing but I hate 90% of
it but I like the final products and the
fun parts of editing but you genuinely
seem to like every single aspect of
editing what's your secret to like
liking editing I don't think there's a
secret but well apparently there is cuz
lot of YouTube editors are just like oh
god well I think I think not not to put
my own uh kind of thoughts on I think
some some people think that like editing
is a as a way to get into YouTube
sometimes and it's kind of like like
they're in it for the wrong reasons well
I I think some people want to be
YouTubers and they think means to an end
yeah I think some people it's a way to
get the foot in the door and sometimes
it actually is but I think sometimes
that YouTube is so mainstream people
know that you can make money from it so
they want to do it but like editing is
Art like why do people like drawing why
do people like like I don't know making
video games it's just creation and for
me it's the same it's not just editing
you know I like uh filming and stuff as
well I'm just the best at editing mhm so
to me it's just making art I guess okay
so it's just it's just making content
[__] I don't know my my videos are art
all right thanks M trash taste is a work
of art guys painted
by next to Mo oh
[__] Con in like museum being like
and this is my ninth crane
grain my finest work do say so myself
this is an excellent piece derivative of
my previous work but still art
nonetheless oh my
God jeez oh so I was going to say
something I totally forgot the sake just
like packed my mind already no no I I
prefer a beer I got to ask do you lose
brain cells when you this I probably
should I don't know if I should say do
you lose brain cells when you edit our
sponsored
segments I got sponsors don't watch the
main episode F sponsors are very basic
i' say uh they I I don't spend that much
time on them and like by now I already
know like every everything in the
beginning I I would say sponsors are one
of the hardest credits cuz those are
actual job like you need to go through
the document to see what has to be
included what not and you need to go
through like 20 minutes of outtakes of
us trying to say one I'm I'm convinced
and like the the depths of my mind that
Mudan has this this file on his PC that
is all of my like me cursing mid sponsor
ad reads I used to have then you were
like oh Mudan can we do patreon bloopers
I'm like ah damnn all right can't
collect anymore because sometimes I'll
do this for ad read and I'll get halfway
through I'm like [__] [__] [__] because
I can't say the word or something I have
like a mental breakdown and only he's
ever going to see it those are the good
ones those are the good ones yeah ones
yeah I just see like a long pause in the
waveform like and then one word in the
middle and then long pause and like all
right what's what's happening there
sometimes that happens I'll be I'll open
a sponsor or something I'll open to do
something I'm going to record it and I'm
like wait I don't have the right stuff
to do this and I'll sit there looking on
my PC for 5 minutes and I realized that
it's just like blank it's just been
rolling me looking like this what the
[__] is that what the [__] is what the
[__] is this okay mov on is it true you
edit at four time speed uh I go through
the videos mostly two times depends on
the videos right but yeah like this
podcast can be done four times a speed
well actually no physically you make it
sound so easy no physically it can cuz
four times a speed like you lose audio
in premiere for some reason so uh right
now I do had
three you're being held back by the
machine your brain's like I can handle
for the computer I canot I used to when
I used to do a lot of my own audio
editing um for voice over I I could I'd
gotten to the point where I could
recognize words from the waveform
because i' would always say them the
same
so I could recognize exactly where the
words were and I think uh you said
something the same thing one time as
well you were like you recognized your
Fox my
[__] I guess cuz I it's the same exact
way for [__] let's see if you see it in
the end um